das schwieriger ist als dass ich schon
relativ heftig bin und jetzt habe ich
auch noch das mit dem zweiten sieht man
besser geht übrigens heute meine ersten
nacht in meiner neuen wohnung in hamburg
direkten date wir allerdings mit flasche
im bett vier wochen pause von youtube
waren glaube ich doch nicht genug
rtr team bett gemacht oder tibet nicht
gemacht bei mir ist relativ klar wenn
ich übrigens von meinem bett ins
badezimmer agieren will habe ich da
einfach sondern fette dreieinhalb meter
hohe schiebetür nicht anmachen
zum glück sehe nicht dass sich untenrum
nicht anders
ich habe ein stativ in köln vergessen
deswegen haben ziemlich ungünstig aber
du musst nicht überall schilder
entstehen über der wohnung ich greife
das doch nicht entstehen wickelt das ist
jetzt halt immer noch das allerneueste
jetzt noch schneller
das ist hier jetzt erst am boden 3 wäre
anspruchsvoll habe ich in sechs ob sie
lautstark das sind noch ein paar seiner
minute läuft und damals bisher nur in
meinem badezimmer aufgehalten
jetzt zum ersten mal seit weihnachten
duschen karlburg nur wenige minuten
später ich habe geduscht und sechs
minuten würden handwerker hier sein habe
ich gar keine richtigen gläser in meiner
neuen wohnung das in die handwerker welt
kommen etwas zu trinken trinken jetzt
einfach so plastikbechern personen haben
von meinen freunden draußen
[Musik]
kino.de auch noch was in meinem blog
sagen
dezember waren sind dass sie dann bei so
staubsauger währungen einfach so ein
komplette musik packung auf dem boden
verstreut
ich wollte man sieht mich das so lässt
wegen dem pulli
wir sagen jetzt erst mal den ganzen
markt wird eingekauft hat sich verletzt
wir haben heute einfach so ja dass dinge
schwarz weil das ist ja vorne aus
schwarz das haben wir aus gefolgt so
einfach weiß ja und immer eine seite
dürfte es doch schwartz nicht so einfach
weiß dass war mit zurück das ding
umtauschen sind doch nicht zurückgesandt
ohren gefahren weil unser drive now a
klasse nicht mehr aufging und dann hat
christian mit den indios 32 deutsch
geredet
das musst du die sache
0151 das ist armin der muss jetzt sein
muss bestellt jeder zweite reihe wie es
haben wir auch so
noch mal ich hab nicht aufgenommen noch
einmal bitte nicht nochmal wir sind
lustig ist echt nice oder ich hab ich
brauche brauche raucher nichtraucher
cool sein wollte oder instagram pushen
in meinem blog laser luca
der export blogger mal wir haben schon
aufgegessen
[Musik]
wie mache ich mich so als putzfrau jetzt
gerade beim staubsaugen aufgefallen dass
mein teppich einfach zu 100 aus
alpakawolle besteht zweite markt in
meiner neuen würde darf man nicht sogar
dass das was man in der ersten nacht in
der wohnung träumt dann in erfüllung
geht also dass das irgendwo manpower ist
er so scheiße das habe ich den geträumt
ich dachte von schnecken mit rund 28 ich
mach' ich will mich weiter nacht
in der neuen wohnung ich habe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und leser gekauft das alles sorgt nicht
dafür dass alles nicht gemacht ihr wisst
ich fühle mich in euren klamotten
wir nehmen jetzt im podcast auf meinem
neuen aufnahme zimmer was halt noch gar
nicht eingerichtet ist und ich glaube
ich habe noch nie mit dem kabelsalat
aufgenommen warum schützen auf dem boden
und ganzen auf deine fresse
[Musik]
wie viele medikamente verschrieben
bekommen fünf oder sechs präsident ich
bin in zwei tagen tot
ja ok dann wieder zu hause angekommen
die augen erzählt mir halt zu zehn
milliarden sachen gegeben die ich jetzt
drauf tragen soll das ist anscheinend
doch ein gerstenkorn in den slums surf
erfolgen sollte ich meine alte
augenärztin hat mir gesagt dass er auf
jeden fall haben wir uns jetzt essen
bestellt also dürft ihr raten was jetzt
wir haben einfach gerade herausgefunden
dass diese kisten hier perfekt rein
passen da darf kein millimeter wir die
kiste größer sein ort die bierkisten
passend auch perfekt jeder also die
kleinen dinge über die man sich dann
freuen
ich wollte um 18 uhr los fahren nach
köln
da muss ich mich auch noch hin ich bin
satte drei stunden zu spät
ich bin einmal müde stelle jetzt noch
was zu essen eigentlich schlafe ich habe
einen anruf bekommen nicht verdienst da
werden die klinik die machen nicht so
ich will dir nicht habe ich das essen
nach hamburg bestellt damals preis geht
an mich dieses jahr ist auf jeden fall
nichts mehr gehe jetzt allerdings
schlafen und falls ihr euch fragt herr
luca warum kam jetzt eigentlich sind wir
brauchen keine videos ich hatte pause
ich habe urlaub ich habe viel mit
freunden gemacht und das braucht sich
auch mal so komplett abschalten
aber jetzt geht's wieder los was ich
genau an wer weiß nicht noch nicht
vielleicht blogs reicht mehr
vielleicht auch
[Musik]
[Applaus]